Michael were you born in Ukraine yes sir
okay so what do you think about what's
going on right now in Ukraine I don't
think I have a very informed perspective
on what's going on my big concern my
background you know uh we talked before
I did a book on North Korea called dear
reader about Kim Jong-il and my big
concern is that we're facing a
replication of the Korean war in the
Korean War you had North Korea with the
great leader Kimmel sung backed by Mao
and Stalin China Russia China and Russia
respectively you had sigmundry in the
South backed by the U.S and the UN and
what ended up happening is Korea the
Korean Peninsula was leveled and the
devastation for the people was enormous
so I'm very concerned that there is
enormous pressure understandably to not
reach any kind of settlement
um and that the people who are going to
end up paying the price of the Ukrainian
people that's my concern people who are
going to end up paying the price of
Ukrainian people if they don't find a
way to settle or even it seems like
there's no good solution here right
because if they're settling it you're
gonna say okay not you I mean the
argument is you're validating Putin's
aggression he's going to do it again
that's a fair argument that it's like
well you can't settle not give an inch
but then like yeah but you're we're here
in America we're not paying the price
but in an anarchy philosophy you've got
to kind of leave it alone right and let
them kind of do their own part I I I I
don't think this is really a question of
libertarian Republican Democrat or
Anarchist I think this is just a
question of right what are what is the
facts of the matter and I don't think I
have the facts on this issue how is that
possible you you it's like your Homeland
like if something happens this is my
homeland no I left here but I get that
but like even uh is there any Affinity
to Ukraine for you none zero no we speak
we spoke Russian I don't even speak
Ukrainian so you were born in Ukraine I
left when I was one and a half so it's
not like I have fond memories it's not
like we left because it was so great and
again but this was the Soviet Union so
Ukraine in 78 is going to be very
different from Ukraine in 2023 and also
Moscow in 78 it's gonna be a difference
that's a little strange though you're
pretty well-read guy and you're a pretty
smart guy to say I don't like uh oh you
know I don't have any uh opinion on the
country I was born in that's going like
it's the topic of discussion on every
single Channel right now yeah uh okay so
if they're so so okay so let's do you
support the fact that U.S has given the
kind of money they're giving and their
uh uh helping them out in this war in a
proxy war type of a thing that's going
on do you support that I would I don't
know because I don't know where this is
going are we going to say that we're
going to just fund it it terminally yeah
uh is or because that seems to be the
premise in which case the ukrainians are
going to be emboldened to fight and then
one day what are we gonna do Cut and Run
and then they're left holding the bag so
that is my concern
okay
it's here's the thing it's not like
Ukraine Russia or the us are going to
somehow regard disregard the legitimacy
of government overnight so this is not a
situation where there's like a like an
anarchist answer or I'm in a position or
an authority to speak for anarchism then
then if that's the case the Anarchy will
never happen if that's the case it's
happening right now this is us and this
is anarchism no but this is at a very
very low level Anarchy well let me let
me rephrase that for Anarchy to happen
at the highest level based on what
you're saying it'll never happen but
there is no highest level under
anarchism the whole point is that if
fine if you want to say that anarchism
can only work in a small community fine
let us have our community and leave us
alone okay so that's then that's what
you are then you would you would uh you
would much rather have your own
Community you go live in with a bunch of
anarchists and you guys created your own
guidelines you gotta land you're happy
with it they don't have to be anarchists
I mean it doesn't here's the thing do
you regard if they're not answering hold
on let me if if one of them is uh if one
of them is ambitious and says look I
have Ambitions in an anarchy system that
guy's eventually going to go and say
here's what I think we should be doing
and if that guy's got better ideas than
yours or is better at selling it than
you then eventually it's going to
convert into a different kind of a
government when you're done not not
necessarily because I don't think that
doesn't make any sense I'd love to hear
it yeah
better ideas are not the ones that
always went out as prohibition
demonstrated because then we repealed it
several years later there's many
examples of the markets where bad ideas
work for a temporary period than they're
rejected but let me just speak to your
point earlier do you if the Chinese
government right now passed the law that
said everyone has to wear orange all the
time would you regard those laws as
valid if China did one if if China
passed the law an edict that said
everyone everyone on Earth has to wear
orange would you find that as legitimate
it'd be weird that's not what I asked
you would you regard as legitimate would
you start wearing orange no why not
because it all look Dutch is that true
they were Orange in Holland I wouldn't I
wouldn't word that's why I'm not living
there right but why why wouldn't you
wear it
it's it's I like my choices okay but do
you regard their that law as legitimate
or not no okay so all anarchism says is
that it regards Washington's laws as
legitimate as those of Beijing you can
say that all you want all I'm thinking
of you is you and I will you shoot this
is anarchy but you should say that
that's great but to to think that this
is at the top level uh you know so so if
I ask you those questions and then I say
well what do you think about what's
going on with Ukraine and well it's I'm
not educated enough two games on okay
but you're from there yeah but I'm an
American myself I understand that but
you're from there yeah but I left when I
was a year and a half I don't remember
anything I'm more like I speak Russian
okay I get that but you have these ideas
of Anarchy in a situation like Anarchy
What should happen over there well we're
not there right now for us to give that
opinion then then your argument loses
weight because it can only carry that
argument can only be sold in low-level
conversations not at high level
conversations a conversation that
carries weight and momentum is is is is
got enough backing to say it would work
if right now let's just say the world
was ran this way here's what would
happen between Russia and Ukraine leave
them alone okay then Ukraine would
become Russia well that's their business
that's not it at all my point is I think
it's important when someone gets on a
mic to come at it from an informed
perspective and I think just because an
issue is very popular in the news that
does not mean that it's not are you are
you gonna let me finish or not that does
not shaking my head doesn't mean you
can't finish fine it doesn't mean that I
have to have an opinion every single
issue and I think a big problem in our
culture is that everyone feels to have
an opinion on every single concern I'm
not a Ukrainian I'm not in Eastern
Europe I've never stepped foot there
since I was one and a half so I don't I
agree with you I don't know how
Anarchist principles would happen in the
middle of a war between Russia and
Ukraine I don't know who the good guys
are then it's listen then it's so then
it's a good conversation to have you
know to go in on shows and all this
other stuff but it's it doesn't carry
enough weight on its own to rule and
they to have a country around it that's
kind of what you're saying but it's not
I'm saying it wouldn't be a country it's
a relationship so number one and second
of all hold on I don't think that if the
U.S was Communist fascist liberal
conservative Progressive I don't think
any of those would inform the question
of what should the U.S do vis-a-vis the
Ukraine and Russia it's not a function
of what government we have what the
right thing to do is over there so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]